[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
free review of the new netflix original
movie red notice this is directed and
written by rawson marshall thurber who
directed skyscraper central intelligence
both films with the rock so this is a
kind of familiar pairing and he also did
were the millers this is the biggest
netflix film in terms of budget and you
have this superstar
cast with these three leads of the rock
ryan reynolds and gallagher dot
now when i watch this film i kept my
expectations at medium here because the
trailer wasn't that exciting to me it
seemed pretty formulaic um but it is
exciting with this cast and what's
interesting about this film is it's
actually really entertaining i was never
bored watching it and that's a huge plus
because most netflix films recently are
all just pretty bad they're they're not
doing great in that department and
that was a breath of fresh air that this
wasn't a total letdown having said that
though
this is a very safe film um it doesn't
move the needle at all in cinema and
what you can expect from
a spy crime thriller with a lot of
comedy here
you've seen everything in this film
before
but
it has this amazing chemistry between
ryan reynolds and the rock that's the
best part of this film is that it is
very funny i thought ryan reynolds here
if you're a fan of this type of humor
you're to really enjoy the scenes with
him and i thought they were all really
funny like i didn't think it was a
misfire in his part i enjoyed it i am a
fan of his humor so
if you like the rock you like ryan
reynolds you're going to enjoy the film
there's no question about it but
the problem with this film is it's very
plot driven the plot is interesting it's
a good plot um it's following a mcguffin
that they're chasing after
but
the plot has a lot of interesting twists
in it
and it keeps moving at a good pace
but there's no character attachment here
and it suffers from that classic sin of
writing a script where you want the plot
coming out of character not the other
way around and what they try to do is
write an interesting plot but just
sprinkle in little character stuff like
you're going to see some
back stories a little bit about the
characters just talk about it about
having bad fathers but
that's with ryan reynolds and the rox
character now the villain here is played
by galaga dot her character is titled
the bishop and she's a very paper thin
character we don't really learn much
about her motivations and intentions at
all which is really disappointing and
it's a miscast to me but this is also a
little bit of a bias because i'm not
super impressed with gal gadot as an
actress and her playing now this villain
who's supposed to have charisma you know
so says some charm
i don't see it at all with her i think
she's just so
bland in her performance here um that
it's not selling me at all anymore on
galaga dot as an actress i'm just not
there i just think it's
really brings down this film a lot i
think you have such great chemistry
between reynolds and the rock and when
her character comes in it's just like
ah it just brings down everything and it
takes you out of it because to me it's
such a poor performance and i'm
complimenting how great the humor is in
that comedy aspect of this film and that
again is a tribute to ryan reynolds in
the rock's chemistry and a lot of the
improvising ryan reynolds is clearly
doing here that that works
but the action is very eh
and
there's some action sequences that look
very fake here so it's disappointing
that it's this big budget film
but you still feel like you'll see the
sequence that's through like the caves
it should be interesting but
it looks like a video game so that's
really disappointing
and what also is really ticks me off
about you'll see it's a lot of netflix
films but
really fake looking sets you're going to
see this particular scene where it's
like a waterfall and they go on this
beach it looks so fake you could tell it
was filmed on a set where it looks like
they're in front of a swimming pool and
there's this fake lighting where problem
a lot of cinematography and netflix
films in particular this one is it's not
you can't look at it as natural lighting
where you're like okay in the context of
the scene
where is that light coming from where
you could tell it's like oh that's a
studio light on the side of his face you
know so that doesn't help with the fake
looking plants around them and it's like
if this is big budget you know couldn't
they not afford to do all these on
location in a real jungle so that's
frustrating as well there's a very you
know artificial feel to the film and
that that this again goes to not great
cinematography here
and a lot of not thoughtful framing or
natural lighting and i'm not saying
natural like you can use obviously
artificial lights but make it look like
there's a justification of where the
light is coming from the scene not that
it just makes it look like it's lit by
film lights and the weird thing about
this film is it is a you know crime
thriller it's got the spy feel to it
with very royalty-free-esque spy music
which is also disappointing there's not
much thought put into the score here and
there's also
with that this jarring tonal shift in
the third act that's very rushed and
feels out of place and it doesn't work
to me
uh it comes with really fun twists
there's like a double twist here which i
like and the problem is it's obsessed
with setting up a franchise and setting
up a sequel which takes away from the
story now and that's why it will feel
rushed which you will see like it's a
classic thing that a lot of hollywood
movies are struggling with now where
they are so obsessed with setting up a
sequel correctly that it takes away from
just a great first film and that film
this film suffers from that but as much
as i'm saying that's bad about this film
a lot of it is good because the other
day you just have these two great
performances by the rock and ryan
reynolds never bored which is huge it's
entertaining film so i think people just
looking for junk food here this film is
junk food like you're gonna enjoy it you
know but
you're not gonna leave it feeling
anything like there's no emotional
attachment here i didn't think anything
after it like you're gonna forget it
like you enjoy it you're never gonna
think about this movie again so overall
though it's not bad and it's not great
so it's a total
meh type of movie and i guess that's
disappointing in the sense of how much
money they put into it but
i'm happy that's not a total failure and
that i did enjoy it overall so i'm
excited to see what you guys think about
it i'm going to give this one a
7.4
let me know what you thought when you
see the film down below it's actually
out in select theater so let me know if
maybe you've already seen it and if you
plan on watching it i'll hear i love to
hear all your thoughts i read every
comment i try to respond as many as i
can please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews i got
dexter review coming up tomorrow so i
can't wait about that i'm reviewing
every episode of that i'm also doing the
wheel of time and i'll be doing more
movie reviews i do celebrity interviews
as well and if you really like what i do
here i'd really appreciate if you sign
up for a membership to get exclusive
perks it'll help me do this full time
one day so i can give you guys more
reviews and please follow me at
stevarlyshow on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me it helps me in
so many ways you have no idea
and i'll see you next time